[Music]
my name is Jerry burs I've been living
in this house for the last ten years
[Music]
fountain Grove is one of the most
beautiful spots in California the
weather is fantastic the flora and the
fauna incredible we have our little
problems with turkeys but I guess
everybody does
I formed some real friendships here with
neighbors a guy across the street makes
storage tanks guy had walked with the
most as a violinist his wife works for
the county
such a beautiful area to walk around
easily it was I went to bed probably
about 11:00 and the neighbors had
windchimes on their back porch and they
were making so much noise and I'm just
clanging I couldn't get to sleep so I
put some cotton in my ears sheriff won't
stand for what have we done on probably
about 1:30 or four three two two I saw
some flashing out the window it looked
like lightning so I got up took the
cotton out of my ears looked out the
window and I could see the fire right up
the street
[Music]
came downstairs opened the front door
and Amber's just flowing right by the
right by the front door
got my wife up and we left immediately I
was really thinking that we might not
make it out I was really nervous about
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we left here at about two o'clock in the
morning and got back up here at 1:30 in
the afternoon the same day
[Music]
as soon as I start driving up the hill
then I know it was gone I know it was
gone
now we're seeing on both sides of the
street just total devastation all my
neighbors they're all gone
every house that reminded me of the
pictures I've seen of Hiroshima
[Music]
but coming around the corner at the top
of the hill I can see that the sight of
my house
through the tree there it was still
standing I almost cried I couldn't
believe it
it was just amazing
[Music]
you're living it's like living in a
desert right now looking out the window
from any direction you see devastation
you can't see any home standing in any
direction it's all burnt charred mess
for that the Lots been cleaned up in
it's just leveled all the neighbors that
I'm really familiar with are gone but
it'll come back they'll be back
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you